at st. Gertrude's a Benedictine abbey
south of berlin the nuns have elected a
new superior and the Cardinal has come
to give her the traditional bishops
blessing let's get da home so shall we
have to find new ways of bringing people
into contact with Christ it isn't enough
to say God loves me or it's important to
love your neighbors it has to be
expressed concretely we need to witness
to the faith in our lives every
Christian has to try and live as
authentically as possible
Adolfo Samuelson though attentively
murkley Souza I am convinced that people
respond to that receives the word soit
this does mention Anjali
in 2011 Heine Mario Berkey a 55 year old
bishop from western Germany was first
appointed Archbishop of Berlin and later
elevated by Pope Benedict to the College
of Cardinals
the decision surprised many not least
perhaps the new Cardinal himself he
found himself suddenly catapulted into a
leadership role at a time when the
church in Europe was facing daunting
challenges and its membership shrinking
dramatically
st. Alphonse is one of 25 Catholic
schools in the Archbishop's diocese
Cardinal Burke II has come to celebrate
the institution's gold from Jubilee
afterthe telephoto comedy after mass he
chats with pupils and teachers but it's
proving rather difficult to break the
ice after posing for several obligatory
photos the cardinal takes the initiative
to move things along other occasions are
rather more daunting the German Bishops
annual reception in Berlin for instance
an opportunity for politicians to
demonstrate their respect for the
Catholic vote and for the bishops to do
some valuable networking as Archbishop
of the German capital it's Vicky's
privilege to welcome the guests together
with the president of the German Bishops
Conference Archbishop robert Sarich
clearly Berlin's new Cardinal is still
finding his feet which every mug is Adam
and Pfizer's from the start that I'm
just the city's Archbishop the fact that
Berlin is the German capital is
irrelevant
and I try to hold to that but I am aware
that the politicians request things of
me and there are expectations in me and
faculties of the anger father Finn
st. Gertrude's Abbey Nestle's in a
sleepy village on the outskirts of the
German capital the Benedictine nuns era
used to welcoming visitors seeking peace
and quiet but the caller today is none
other than the busy archbishop of Berlin
himself who has come to give the new
Abbess her symbols of office
Benedictines elect their superiors sent
this time they've chosen a young member
of the community sister Bernadette the
Cardinal will give her the traditional
blessing known as the Episcopal
benediction confirming her election
fewer and fewer German Catholics are
choosing the monastic life so this is a
special occasion for the Cardinal before
conferring his blessing on the new
Abbess Cardinal volca formally asks her
if he is ready to live according to the
rule of Saint Benedict one the humanist
issues if she's ready to lead her
community by example and if she's ready
to accept her sister's salvation as her
first responsibility 1zd in an unfit out
inch waist on to all three questions the
new Abbess answers yes I am ready yes
defleshed Unzen
monasteries and convents are spiritual
beacons in a world that denies the
existence of God
Cardinal Volker would like to see a few
more of them in his sprawling diocese in
terms of area it's the second largest in
the country and extends beyond the
German capital into the thinly populated
federal states of Brandenburg and
mecklenburg-vorpommern less than 10% of
the population here is Catholic and
atheism is deeply rooted the result of
decades of communist rule which does
finish take it all the course that
causes me pain the faith that is the
basis of my life if even the reason for
my becoming a priest it means everything
to me and I believe we can give people
orientation and help in their lives a
tremendous perspective with the gospel
that we would claim and worship so of
course it saddens me we'll have a
perspectiva - our genes all fun for good
which that's not truly but on the other
hand I see this a B this is spiritual
oasis advised us here I think a fine
chef and I'm very grateful for this
community of about 30 women were trying
to express the essence of the Gospels in
their lives
Inez tensed as if I'm Gilliam's concrete
though here and liebenzell talks about
Stokes O'Brien
the Cardinal visits a class of
fourth-graders sensing that his clerical
garb may be intimidating to the children
he makes an effort to put them at their
ease
I am a bishop we are men who are sent
like the Apostles to show other people
by our lives that God is alive and that
he cares about people the Cardinal is
strongly aware of the importance of
education he himself comes from a humble
background born in Cologne in 1956 he
grew up in a staunchly Catholic family
family was deeply religious religious my
parents used to say prayers with the
children so did my grandma who lived
with us and we went to church on Sunday
at Patricia's Whedon's Kingdom Gabby ate
it and visions on texts and got the
stain stick again there was nothing
unusual about this nothing excessive it
was just a normal Catholic upbringing
that left it stamped on me normal Ghalib
this catalyst christen tomb the
certificate pract I became an altar boy
minister and the assistant priest was my
role model and see about the way he
lived how he treated the young people
was authentic I wanted to be like him is
the Spartan Tish on man wounds were ugly
Jovie there is so much dust - I'm aware
annamaria Berkey may have wanted to
remain just a simple parish priest but
the church had other plans
in 2012 pope benedict xvi
elevated him to the College of Cardinals
Santa Anas Maria viene in nomine Patris
et filii et spiritus sancti
the German capital was a challenge
whereas the Rhineland is traditionally
Catholic Berlin is home to just 325
thousand Catholics fewer than 10% of the
city's residents
but Berkey is not intimidated by this
secular society he sees it as a
challenge to bring people in contact
with Christ and the number of Catholics
in his diocese is currently growing as
immigrants arrived from Poland southern
Europe and South America
which began in Berlin what - up -
Nutkins I like being in Berlin well I
like the city because it has a
tremendous amount to offer especially
culturally to beat nut god of quitter
Elam the beat - - building in that
aspect it's probably unique in Germany
it have dimension and I like the people
because they received me spontaneously
with openness and walk and a hellish cat
beginning from begin undeviated with
billiard applet really of course I also
know another Berlin Lance for whether
glitter and glamour that the tourists
see is less evident there is poverty
here in Houston and the gap between rich
and poor is constantly growing than
undecayed that especially affects young
people and children came down julie
teeger was on duster puffins ind
the Cardinal lives in a district viewed
by many as a social flashpoint in his
rented accommodation on a busy street he
says he feels at home among the people
he is called to serve his office is
located on the building's ground floor
various diocesan committees meet here
every Tuesday in effect the archbishop
is like a parish priest only on a larger
scale his first concern is to meet the
pastoral needs of the people in his
diocese
for me it's taken it's got I think the
most important thing is that God created
people and that he loves his creation
that's their Minj so he loves human
beings people have dignity because
they're created in the image of God
every person irrespective of class or
color the social situation or background
is precious and I can encounter
something of God in every person there
this person is not heading into a void
but has a goal and that goal is a life
in God and with God in God what a mighty
God is or basically it is everything we
long for existential yes ultimately it
means happiness and love and acceptance
unconditional acceptance unbeliever and
we receive it as a gift from God and we
are in God ashamed
in the district where the Cardinal lives
a third of the people belong to ethnic
minorities
unemployment is high in the standard of
living falls below the national average
but the social mix highlights the ethnic
and religious diversity of contemporary
Germany the Cardinal feels at home here
a short distance from his office there's
a church sponsored cafe that provides
help for kids in the district hello
everyone today I'm here on my own
without the board members I was here
just two or three weeks ago but I
thought I'd drop by alone this time of
course it's nice that you don't just
come for anniversary celebrations I'm
not off the phones actually we wanted to
ask you a favor
do you have any time on st. Joseph's Day
it's on March 17th or thereabouts
19th 19th or the 17th would you help the
kids with their homework for an hour you
can find out what it's really like here
reveal my ignorance oh I doubt that
oh only you knew I'm not very good at
mathematics oh you'll manage I do and
math isn't my strength
cuz Walker Manor was I try not to forget
my roots that I come from a rather
humble background and Ferguson comma and
others upwards so house my parents home
was very simple young and East and for
diesel even steel and for her I try to
maintain that simple lifestyle I do my
own laundry make my own breakfast do my
own shopping I like to take care of
these things myself as everyone else
does Vieira and Ozzie all faded this is
the clothing you were asking about the
normal dress that is worn on official
occasions great respondents or by
official bazoo contact for a church man
Cardinal Burke II hold strong political
views he argues that Christianity is
inherently political he gets involved in
the city's social problems he's media
savvy and not intimidated by politicians
he's a good listener and also a good
raconteur his manner is direct and
simple
so that was a dear - feisty I don't know
about representing anything of course
it's part of my job to deal with
politicians when I arrived in Berlin and
I couldn't imagine myself doing that it
was definitely not my niche area and
probably still isn't the Swazi here we
go Madhavi but I do my best because it's
part of the job anybody sitting on
mission get bargain Walden's in November
last year was the 75th anniversary of
the pogrom the Nazis called Reich's
Krista knocked the night of broken glass
in 1938 Hitler's henchmen torched
synagogues and attacked Jewish
businesses across Germany the
anniversary was also commemorated by
Berlin's Christians
well again the Burgermeister mr. mayor
bishop burger
ladies and gentlemen November the 9th is
a day of remembrance we call to mind the
pogroms of November 1938 but we should
also remember the silence that reigned
over the whole of Germany and was not
really broken even in the church's
border we have to take responsibility
for that and be ashamed
when asked if he considers himself
progressive or conservative Cardinal
Varkey answers without hesitation
conservative he likes to talk about the
roots of his faith the Christian message
from which the church lives he agrees
with Pope Francis that the church should
be poor that it should serve the poor
it must proclaim love and social justice
the church must always be ready to
reform itself and it must do so by
comparing itself with its roots the
gospel looking at the world in which we
live we have to try and see the
present-day challenges where is God in
this world in the many social issues
that concern us
this father the field fog and since it's
a land by bush ft in the church has to
be the advocate of the poor and needy
denotes India that is the way it has to
reform itself and change their form it
has to live more authentically India be
more like the gospel or tend to sure
Zion most leave most if a Gilliam's
kabisa design most leave most I think
the Pope is a good example of this
despite challenging in the way he
doesn't cost for a honk
twisty art be a dust wood
Berkey knows the questions that need to
be asked but does he have answers to the
church's problems
he believes the church needs to return
to its roots to equip itself for the
challenges of the present the core the
church's identity he says is Jesus of
Nazareth his thought his words his
actions and that says the Cardinal is
what should determine the church's own
thoughts words and actions
he appears relaxed and I think he is
he's a spiritual person and he's
definitely good for Berlin SEK would fit
best in belly and he stirred things up a
bit of course he still has to become
familiar with the diocese and see how
his wishes fit in with the circumstances
here but I think that will come with
time
and he's open-minded inside bringing
more days off enough Fuhrer
while visiting a Catholic school in
Berlin the Cardinal tries to speak the
children's language one as much as what
keeps the Deaf right side it's fine he
tells them that soccer is a lesson in
social behavior a good player is always
aware of what the other members of his
team are doing at any moment that's when
the teens Wilson Fubini Lincoln could
the Cardinal draws a bold parallel
between Jesus and the soccer coach Jesus
he tells the children is like a coach
who gives his team the right strategy
for coexisting with others in BRIC
Ferdinand on the Z naming the Smeaton
under the cyst mine life if your oil
ginger gaben with more than a billion
members worldwide the catholic church
could be described as a multinational
association to survive as an institution
it has to have an organizational
structure with the hierarchy and rules
but the Cardinal is adamant those are
not the essentials
he says the church's main task is to
bring people into contact with Christ to
kill here about which defy the
foundation of the church is the
celebration of the Eucharist and it's
not the priest the bishop or the Pope
who breaks the bread they simply make
crisis the head of the church present
president he is the one who proclaims
his word who baptizes confirms and who
breaks the bread and distributes it
there wins the sport and our style but
Indy when he gives himself to us we
become one with him and also brothers
and sisters yes one body in him
Southwest on a Buddha or damn it in in
ants
to einem life
many German Catholics have turned their
backs on religion but the churches will
to reform exemplified by Pope Francis
and echoed by Berlin's Archbishop is
winning new respect
the message is clear the church must
become an advocate of the poor and needy
she must identify with the poor
goddess finish their heart - Levens God
is the mainstay of my life a LaDonna
Zenon Dileep design I think we all want
to be loved and accepted
what does HUMINT is but there is nobody
who can give us unconditional support
you think those of the islands I hear a
phone ones and / Vania mention on the
one hand we all have a few people we
believe hope will give us the support we
need above it does he does for Liam will
test us by didn't of the finalists
I wish finally I think we can only find
the security we're looking for in God
information when my late evening got so
home